The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, now we'll start
on the last of the main topics
in the course.
So we've finished most of our
macroscopic thermodynamics,
and our microscopic
approach to it
through statistical mechanics.
And now, our final topic
is kinetics.
Kinetics is really a very
different kind of topic.
Because unlike thermodynamics,
thermodynamics tells you all
about equilibrium properties.
A huge part of the work of this
term has been to figure
out what equilibrium is.
What is the equilibrium state,
given some situation.
You've got some phases
present.
Different then, you could go
from solid to liquid to gas.
Or you've got different chemical
constituents together
that can react and go
back and forth.
What are the equilibrium
concentrations?
But we haven't worried at all
about how long it might take
to get there.
And that's what kinetics does.
Kinetics is concerned with rates
of reactions, primarily.
How long it takes to
reach equilibrium.
And of course it's
super-important.
Because if you look at that
window glass, it's not in
equilibrium.
It's silicon dioxide,
the equilibrium
state would be a crystal.
It would be crystal
and quartz.
Nevertheless, none of us is
very worried that on the
moment it's likely to suddenly,
spontaneously turn
into a crystal and be opaque and
scatter light and do all
that sort of stuff.
And in lots of other situations,
certainly if you
look at any living biological
system, including yourselves
or your friends or any other
one, it's certainly far from
equilibrium.
And you probably would hope
for it to stay that way.
So there's an enormous amount
of chemistry and processes
we're concerned with.
Which depend intimately on
kinetics in order to work the
way they work.
They also do depend on
thermodynamics and where
equilibrium states are.
But that doesn't mean
they necessarily
reach equilibrium states.
So we're going to go through
kinetics, starting with the
simplest examples and working
our way up to
more complex cases.
And just see how we can describe
elementary chemical
reaction rates and processes.
So that's our concern
now, is dynamics.
How long things take to
get to equilibrium.
And actually just like
macroscopic thermodynamics,
kinetics does take an empirical
approach to the topic.
In other words, it's based on
experimental observation.
Of macroscopic rates.
How long it takes a collection
of stuff, a mole of stuff to
change chemically.
And undergo reaction.
And so forth.
We often infer molecular
mechanisms based on kinetics.
And it's hugely important
and valuable to do that.
But it's also important to
recognize that what kinetics
can do is show us how we can
formulate microscopic
mechanisms that might be
consistent with our
macroscopic kinetics models.
But the kinetics models
by themselves
don't prove the mechanism.
And there are all sorts of
examples where mechanisms that
were proposed and accepted
because they were consistent
with macroscopic kinetics
results turned out to fail.
There are other ways to
prove mechanisms.
You might be able to design
direct spectroscopic
observations of intermediates
and so forth.
And in that case, it often
becomes possible to
distinguish between different
mechanisms.
Which might all satisfy the
macroscopic kinetics equation.
So we use kinetics to infer a
mechanism but not necessarily
to prove it.
Not generally to prove it.
We also use kinetics to describe
an enormous range of
time scales.
So, the fastest things that
we're sometimes concerned with
that might take place on
femtosecond time scales, 10 to
the minus 13 seconds
or so, or 10 to the
minus 15 seconds, even.
So, if we look at the range
of time scales we might be
concerned with, might go
anywhere from about 10 to the
minus 15 seconds at the fastest,
and might go to
enormous scales on
the other end.
All the way out to maybe 10 to
the 10 seconds, which is on
the thousands of years.
Could be longer than
that, sometimes
even millions of years.
And the formalism that we'll set
up applies equally to the
full range of time scales.
So it can describe an enormous
amount of chemical activity.
More commonly, for stuff that
we're going to compare to, you
might measure in the lab.
Common time scales range from
roughly 10 to the minus 6
seconds out to about 10
to the 5th seconds.
That is, microseconds
to about a day.
But there are plenty of examples
of going either
faster or slower, depending on
the need and the experimental
equipment available.
Let's define a few terms.
Let's talk about how we're
going to just formulate
chemical reaction rates.
So, let's just imagine any
simple reaction of this sort.
So A plus B are going to go to
C. There's some rate at which
it happens.
Note, by the way, it's an
arrow in one direction.
It's not an equals sign
like we've seen
before, or a double arrow.
So the point I'm emphasizing
here is when we talk about
reaction rates, unlike
equilibria, we're talking
about a particular direction.
Later on, we will talk about
reversible reactions.
But there, too, the arrow going
this way refers only to
one of the chemical reactions
that can take place.
Namely, in this case, the
changing of what was the
product now, would be the
reactant, C, back into A plus
B and it has nothing to do
with the rate this way.
Measured independently
and so on.
So the rate, we can look at the
rate of disappearance of
A. So it's just negative
d[A]/dt, where the brackets
indicate concentration.
Usually in moles per liter.
If it's in a gas, then it would
be pA, of pressure.
So negative d[A]/dt
is our rate.
And note that that's generally
a positive number.
We're looking at reactions
going, if it's a reaction
going in this direction.
A is gradually disappearing.
So we're going to define
our rate this way.
To be a positive number.
The rate for C is going
to be plus d[C]/dt.
It's also going to be
defined in a way
that makes it positive.
Because in this case, since the
reaction's going this way,
we're looking at the
appearance of C.
Now, by stoichiometry , in this
case, of course whenever
a molecule or a mole of A
disappears, a molecule or a
mole of C appears.
So because of that, in this
case, the stoichiometry tells
us that that d[C]/dt is equal
to negative d[A]/dt.
And also equal to negative
d[B]/dt.
And any of those can be used to
define the rate of reaction.
Now, this is a particularly
simple case because I've
chosen the case where all
of the stoichiometric
coefficients are equal to one.
So now let's just look at any
case that's different.
Let's look at 2A plus B goes to
something else, 3C plus D.
And just look at the reaction
rates that we might see there.
So here now, the appearance of
C is going to be three times
as fast as the appearance
of D, for example.
And also three times as fast as
the disappearance of B. So
if we write negative d[B]/dt,
we expect that's going to be
negative 1/2 d[A]/dt.
In other words, A is going to
disappear twice as fast as B.
Every time a molecule of B
reacts, two molecules of A do.
And that's going to be plus 1/3
d[C]/dt, and every time
that happens three molecules
of C get formed.
And it's going to
be plus d[D]/dt.
One molecule of D gets formed.
And so, the reaction rate could
be defined in terms of
any of these.
But the important thing is to
keep track of stoichiometry so
that the rate as it pertains
to each constituent is
accounted for correctly.
So to generalize, if I have
little a of A, and little b of
B, going to little c of C, and
little d of D, then the rate
of reaction can be written as
minus one over a d[A]/dt, or
minus one over b d[B]/dt, or
one over c d[C]/dt, or one
over d d[D]/dt.
So, experimentally, lots of
measurements of reaction rates
have been made.
And now to start on what's seen
empirically, basically
the following result is
extremely common.
The rate is equal to some
constant times the
concentration of A to some
power alpha, times the
concentration of B to some
power beta, and so on.
For all reactants.
Multiplied together,
each concentration
taken to some power.
Notice no products.
Again, we're only looking at
a reaction going one way.
And if we look at the
rate, this is
typically what's found.
Alpha is called the order of
reaction, with respect to A.
Beta order with respect
to B. And so on.
And little k is our rate
constant which, just to make
clear, since we've been using it
extensively in the past few
lectures, is completely
not equal to
the Boltzmann constant.
Absolutely no connection
between them.
Now, alpha and beta, what they
are, what they turn out to be,
is typically what's determined
as a result of kinetic
measurement.
Typically they're
small integers.
So, just sort of a typical
example, if you look at the
reaction of NO and O2, to make
NO2, simple reaction, and you
look at minus d[O2]/dt, use
that as a measure of the
reaction rate.
What's found is that it's
a constant times NO
concentration squared,
times O2.
Simple, right?
One of the exponents is
two, the other's one.
Doesn't seem so surprising
mechanistically.
But it's not always the case.
Even when you have small
integers, it's not always the
case that the most obvious
mechanism you would infer is
the real mechanism.
And sometimes those exponents
don't turn
out even to be integers.
But here's another example.
If you just look it CH3CHO going
to methane and carbon
monoxide, seems like it would
be a pretty straightforward
thing, too.
So if you measure, for
example, the rate of
appearance of methane, what
you discover is that it's
equal to a constant times the
concentration of the starting
material to the 3/2 power.
Not obvious mechanistically why
that should be the case.
Usually it's telling
us something.
It's telling us that the
reaction mechanism is
complicated.
It's a multi-step process.
Sometimes there could be chain
reactions and so forth.
So again, seeing things like
this certainly helps us to
infer molecular mechanisms.
Again, they don't prove
molecular mechanisms.
But they certainly can be very
helpful in suggesting them.
And then other means can be
used to try to prove them.
Including, above all, direct
observation of the
intermediates that you would
expect on the basis of one
mechanism or another.
Now let's just go through some
elementary examples of
kinetics one at a time.
So let's start with the simplest
possible case.
Actually, a very rare case, but
one that'll help us just
set up the formalism
of, and the
mechanism for us to proceed.
So let's talk about zero
order reactions.
Actually very rare.
So, what this means is
something like A
goes over to products.
Make a measurement of d[A]/dt,
and discover that it's k time
A to the power of zero,
that is, it's just k.
There's no dependence on the
concentration of A. Or
anything else.
And you have some rate
of its disappearance.
So here's an example of it.
You could have oxalic acid,
and it just turns into
hydrogen carbon dioxide
and carbon dioxide.
Things break apart, forms
these products.
Make a measurement of
the disappearance.
Seems to have nothing to do with
the concentration of it.
At least under certain
conditions.
Now, turns out that there's
another element that helps
understand this.
Turns out that light
is needed, it's a
photochemical reaction.
And then it's easy to see
how this can happen.
Let's say we have an abundance
of the starting material, and
not very much light.
So every now and then photons
bleed in, and every now and
then when they're absorbed,
it leads to dissociation.
In that situation, you'll be
limited by the photons, but
not by the concentration
of the molecules.
And in fact, strictly speaking
although this is zero order in
terms of the chemical
constituents, it's not zero
order in the photons.
So in some sense, in this sort
of situation, the photons
should be considered one
of the reactants.
You could write this as this
plus h nu plus one photon,
goes over to these products.
And then if you measure the
rate and things are under
circumstances like I described,
you would discover
that in fact yes you'd
be photon limited.
The rate would depend
on how many both
photons are coming in.
Still, ordinarily, chemical
rate equations aren't
formulated in those terms.
So in the usual formulation,
this would still have the
appearance of a zero
order reaction.
Now, how do we write and
formulate a solution?
So it's simple.
We've we've written a
differential equation here.
It's a pretty straightforward
one.
Minus d[A]/dt is just
a constant.
So we can solve it.
And typically we'll solve it by
rewriting in integral form
and then doing the integration
as long as we can do the
integration.
So from here we can write the
integral from starting
concentration [A]0 to some other
concentration, [A], d[A]
is equal to minus k integral
from zero to t dt.
So all we've done is integrate
on both sides.
And we've assumed a starting
concentration.
We've assumed an initial
condition.
And we've also assumed an
initial time, which usually we
can just call zero.
And this is, of course,
something we can solve for
straight away.
So we just have that [A] minus
[A]0 is negative kt minus
zero, which is minus kt.
So [A] is minus kt.
Plus [A]0.
In other words, the
concentration of [A] at any
time is given by the initial
concentration, minus the rate
constant times time.
It decays linearly in time.
So we can sketch that.
This is our initial
concentration.
And then it's just going to
decline with time after that.
And there's our solution.
In lots of cases, it's
useful to define
what's called a half-life.
It's just useful.
Because it provides some
timeframe, a single number
that's a timeframe on which
the reaction occurs.
So, the half-life is just the
time that it takes for half of
the reactants to disappear.
t 1/2 time to
react half the reactants.
OK, so in this case it's
straightforward to see when
that happens.
In other words, that's the
time at which this
concentration of A is just
equal to [A]0 over two.
So we have [A]0 over two is
minus kt 1/2 plus [A]0 or t
1/2 is equal to [A] over 2k.
[A]0 over 2k.
So there's our half-life.
So if we go over here,
we can put that in.
[A]0 over two, and this
time is our half-life.
So that's zero order
reactions.
And, again, zero order
reactions are rare.
But the procedure we're going to
used to solve for kinetics
is outlined in this way.
And we'll use that
again and again.
Let's look at first-order
kinetics.
Let's go over here.
Now, first order reactions
are quite common.
Much, much more common
than zero order.
So here, you have A
goes to products.
That's the simplest case.
But this time if we measure
d[A]/dt, we discover that it's
equal to a constant times the
concentration of A. There's an
important point to note here.
What are the units of
k, in this case.
What do they have to be?
Yeah, reciprocal
seconds right?
The equation has to work.
This is concentration
per second.
This is concentration.
This better be per second.
Let's just, before we move on
completely, look at this.
What are its units?
Here's the equation.
What are the units of k?
No, not unitless, because,
look at this.
This is some concentration
unit,
typically moles per liter.
So this is moles per liter
per second, right?
It's disappearance of some
concentration for time.
That's got to be here.
All that is here.
Moles per liter per second.
So in every case, the units of
k, the rate constant, have to
be figured out on the basis of
the specific rate equation.
Doesn't have the same units.
When the kinetics are
of different order.
Now, let's solve this using the
same approach as before.
Namely, this is still a
pretty straightforward
differential equation.
So let's just integrate
both sides.
So that is going to tell us the
integral from [A]0 to [A].
But now we have [A]
on this side.
So here we just had
a constant.
And effectively, I didn't
write it out.
But we effectively wrote this,
rewrote this, as d[A]
equals minus k dt,
and then went
from here to the integral.
We're going to do the
same thing here,
except now there's this.
So really we're going
to have d[A]
over [A] is minus k dt.
That's what we're going to
integrate on both side.
We need to have the variables
distinct on each side.
So we have d[A]
over [A].
Equal to minus k integral
from zero to t dt.
And so, of course, you know
how to do this integral.
It's going to look
like log of [A].
And again, it's taken
at [A] or, at [A]0.
So we have log of
[A] over [A]0.
We're going to have log of [A]
minus log of [A]0 coming out.
And that's equal to minus kt.
So now the kinetics are
quite different.
We have [A] is equal to [A]0,
e to the minus kt.
Very important, very common
sort of result.
It's saying we start with a
certain amount of material,
and there's an exponential
decay of it.
So very different from
kinetics here,
which are just linear.
And again the kinetics here, if
you imagine that situation
where you've got starting
material and bleeding in
gradually are photons,
presumably at the same rate,
then sure that material you're
going to see the disappearance
of it linearly with time.
Just depending on the
rate at which the
photons are coming in.
Here it's very different
because, presumably, A is
required in order to
do this reaction.
It'll depend on how much.
Because of course if there's
more of it, you'll just have
more at any given time decaying
over to products.
So you have an exponential
decay.
So let's plot that.
Here's [A], let's
make that [A]0.
There it is.
Now, let's look at what happens
to the product.
So let's imagine that it's A
going to B, so of course minus
d[A]/dt is just equal to
d[B]/dt, and the rate of
appearance of B has to match the
rate of disappearance of
A. Let's assume that we
don't have any of
B present at first.
So let's make [B]0
equal to zero.
Well then, [B] just has to equal
[A]0 minus [A], right?
All the stuff that's left, all
of the A that has disappeared,
that's given by this
difference.
Is just equal to B. So that's
just [A]0 minus concentration
of A, but that's just
given by that.
Which is [A]0 e to
the minus kt.
Or in other words, [B] is just
equal to [A]0 times one minus
e to the minus kt.
So at t equals zero, this
is zero and this is one.
In other words, this is going
to be zero at first.
And then it's going to grow in
with the same exponential form
that this decayed.
So, [B] is going to do
the exact opposite.
It's going to be like this.
So this is [B] of t and this is
[A] of t equals [A]0 e to
the minus kt.
Now, it's always useful to,
whenever possible, to plot
these things linearly.
Find a way to plot these
as straight lines.
And of course in this case it's
straightforward to do
that as a log plot.
So if we take the log of both
sides, we know of course that
the log of [A] is just minus kt,
plus the log of [A]0, so
now let's look at that.
Make this the log of [A]0 and
this is the log of [A]
on the axis.
That'll be time.
So there's just some
linear decay now.
And the slope is minus k.
So experimentally, of course,
this'll be done typically as a
simple way of determining it.
Now, we also can usefully look
at the half life, in this
case, in the case of first
order kinetics.
So we have an expression
in general for [A].
So if we let [A] equal [A]0 over
two, at t equals t 1/2,
that tells us that log of [A]0
over two divided by [A]0 is
minus kt to the 1/2.
But this is just the log of two,
or log of two is over k
is t to the 1/2.
And so t to the 1/2 is
just 0.693 over k.
So we can write that just
generally, completely
independent of whatever [A] is,
also independent of what
[A]0 is, and that makes sense.
So the point is, if you have
something that just
spontaneously decays into
products, maybe it's just
gradual chemical decomposition
of something.
Spontaneously, without the
participation of other
constituents.
There's a general half-life
that can be
associated with that.
That'll just be related
directly to
the rate of the decay.
So it's knowable and measurable
in a simple form.
And again, the half-life
is always useful.
Because it just gives a simple,
one-number measure of
the rough timescale for
things to change.
So if we go back to this plot,
and then once again here's our
half concentration.
And here's our t 1/2, just a
useful way of summarizing in a
simple way, what happens.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ooh.
Well, I didn't think about it.
But it isn't necessary
that that'll happen.
Sure seems like it must be.
When one is half decayed, the
other must be half formed as
long as there wasn't any
B present at first.
So yeah, thank you.
Well, given that, something
needs to move.
But let's pretend like I got it
right at this intersection.
Even though it doesn't
look that good.
So really it should be there.
Thank you.
So the single most common
example of first order
kinetics of this form is
radioactive decay.
You've got some radioactive
isotopic that can
spontaneously decay into
some other nucleus.
And of course, this is measured
and half-lives have
been tabulated for lots
of cases of this sort.
So a simple example.
Let's look at carbon-14.
It's got a nuclear
charge of six.
It can decay into nitrogen-14
through
the loss of an electron.
Happens.
First order kinetics.
Now, in the atmosphere, what
happens is this will end up,
the 14C ends up getting
replenished..
Because from cosmic rays, what
can happen is in the
atmosphere, you can have your
nitrogen plus a neutron will
come and form 14C plus
a hydrogen atom.
So in fact, the overall
concentration in the
atmosphere of 14C tends to
be constant over time.
But stuff that's formed down
here on Earth, with carbon,
its content of 14C decays over
time, and it doesn't get
replenished.
So, let's think back
some long time ago.
Here's a tree. we can
make it pretty.
So it's got some concentration
of 14C that came from carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere.
That's what it started with.
That's our starting point.
At some point later, through
natural occurrence or human
intervention, that tree
became horizontal.
Then, and although we're looking
back here, let's call
this our t equals zero.
And our 14C concentration
at the time is our
concentration at zero.
Now let's say, shortly after
that, either right after
because of deliberate action,
or shortly after because it
was just discovered, somebody
decides to build something
using that tree.
So, early human craft.
And then let's say lots later,
depending on your definition
of lots, modern human, which can
be denoted by this style
of hat, makes exciting
discovery.
Terrific.
And would like to know
how old is it.
How long ago did all
that stuff happen.
Let's assume this is also
approximately t equals zero.
Well, so a log of [14C]
over [14C]0.
So this carbon dating,
all it's really doing
is measuring that.
It gives a number for it.
And we know this because we're
assuming it hasn't changed any
in all those years.
In the atmosphere.
It's different down here,
because the tree or the boat
wasn't replenished.
Not nearly as many cosmic
rays fell on it.
So that's minus log of t.
And it turns out the t
1/2 is 5,760 years.
Amazing, that this can be
known down to ten years.
But it is.
So that says, k his 0.693
divided by t to the 1/2, which
is one over 8,312 years.
So there's our answer, then.
The time, how long ago that
happened, is just minus 8,312
years times the log of [14C]
in the artifact.
Divided by the log
of, by [14C]
in the air.
And the assumption again is that
this is the same now as
it was back then.
And there's a bigger number than
this, so it's a positive
number overall.
So in a fairly straightforward
way, we'll use first order
kinetics to determine
the lifetime of
something like this.
Because we know the
rate constant.
And everything else follows.
Let's see.
Next there's going to be
second order kinetics.
But let me just stop here and
say just a word about the exam
on Wednesday.
So I've handed out an
information sheet about it.
But I don't have anything very
different to say this time
than I've had to say about
previous exams.
Solve lots of problems.
Go over the homework.
Go over practice problems.
Try last year's exam as
a sample exam when
you're ready to do it.
Try it under test conditions.
There's nothing on the exam that
you're going to look at
and say oh my God, how was I
supposed to know that we ought
to study that.
There won't be any surprises.
Most of the exam questions so
far, not all have been easy,
but I think they've been more
or less plain vanilla in the
sense that they're right more
or less down the middle of
what we're trying to teach.
And not very many are taking off
little peripheral elements
of the class.
And it's not going to be
any different here.
So if you can just do the
problem solving and get
familiar enough with it that
you're just good at it, so
that you can do it with a
reasonable speed, you're going
to be fine.
Also try to work on just
understanding the
underpinnings.
Especially of statistical
mechanics.
That's where when you have these
true-false or multiple
choice questions, these sort
of thought exercises.
Those are really hard.
Because they go a little bit
beyond problem solving.
If you could do the
problem solving,
you're going to do fine.
But it's always useful if you
can also formulate things.
And for that, it's never easy
to just tell you here's what
you have to do, to
get good at this.
Because you have to
think about it.
And it's always hard.
But to be sure, if you can just
try when you review the
statistical mechanics,
especially, and you review the
expressions that you use and
how you solve problems with
them, the next step in studying
is to try to think,
OK, do I really understand
where that
expression came from.
And why it makes sense
physically.
And if you can do that, then
so much the better.
Then you'll be in an even
stronger position.
The info sheet gives a handful
of equations that we do expect
you to come in with those
on your fingertips.
There are not very many.
Mostly we'll provide expressions
that you'll need,
and the important thing is that
you know, understand,
where they apply.
And how to use them.
So, good luck on Wednesday.